fans are freaking out over in this new  photo of Hugh Jackman what they did to  me can't be undone 47 year old actor  looks noticeably older in the Instagram  snap of himself giving the camera  thumbs up there's a tray of cooked fish  in front of him and he wrote now that's  what I'm talking about  his followers went wild in the comment  section wondering why he looked so  different and he does  compared to this pic we dug up of him  from April at a gala in New York but  Hughes altered appearance may just be  makeup he's working on the third  Wolverine installment I wake up in my  younger body and then what and while the  plot is being kept under wraps some fans  think he was teasing a first look at old  man Logan old man Logan is said to  follow a Wolverine who has given up on  violence and who keeps his claws to  himself maybe there's someone in the  park one will say  you